former un gouvernement ou s'en aller
c'est le choix que l'ess michel aoun à
saad hariri
le président libanais s'est adressé
directement à son premier ministre lors
d'une allocution télévisée il a exigé
qu'ils mettent immédiatement en place un
cabinet ou qu'il quitte son poste s'il
se trouve dans l'incapacité de former et
de diriger un gouvernement de salut
national chargé de faire face à la
situation dangereuse qui secoue le pays
ses habitants ou d'un d'autre choix que
de céder la place à tous ceux qui sont
capables de mener cette tâche je lance
un appel sincère au premier ministre
désigné pour qu'il choisisse rapidement
l'une des deux options un ultimatum
auquel a répondu saad hariri le premier
ministre désigné a renvoyé la
responsabilité de ce blocage au
président à son tour il a invité à
prendre ses responsabilités si le
président se trouve incapable de signer
le décret formant ce gouvernement
capable de mettre en oeuvre les réformes
nécessaires pour arrêter l'effondrement
dont souffre le pays alors il devrait
ouvrir la voie à une élection
présidentielle anticipée
le premier ministre a été désigné en
octobre dernier pour former son équipe
il a succédé à hassan diab qui a
démissionné quelques jours après les
explosions du port de beyrouth le 4 août
dernier
des désaccords et une mésentente
politiques qui rendent la formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement improbable mais ces
divergences prennent place dans un
contexte de chaos économique pour les
libanais la population s'appauvrit de
jour en jour et les manifestations quasi
quotidiennes sont parfois violentes pour
débloquer la situation
européens et américains pourraient
accroître les pressions sur la classe
politique libanaise afin d'obtenir la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
ornements selon une source diplomatique
française
cela pourrait passer par des sanctions